well I have a question I guess I'd like
to know a little bit more about why you
specifically chose the title the master
and the emissary yeah that that's to
meterics plain what I believe to be the
relationship is Union hemispheres and
they like most other things in life
they're in equal and asymmetrical and
that one of the brain hemispheres sees
more than the other that is the one that
I've designated the most it mm-hmm and
it was the right hemisphere mm-hmm
that's a weird inversion because people
often think of the left hemisphere is
the one that's like dominant they do
they do traditionally that's been the
case but as is becoming ever clearer the
right hemisphere this has been a real
steep learning curve for some people but
the variety emma sphere is in many ways
more reliable sees more understands more
than the left hemisphere is like a sort
of hybrid high functioning bureaucrat in
a way mm-hmm and the idea of the story
was simply that certain matters needed
to be delegated not only because as it
were the master couldn't do everything
he needed an emissary to go abroad and
do some of it but also that he must not
get involved with a certain point of
view otherwise he'd lose what it was
that he did to see so that's what I'm
really saying there is that there's a
good reason why
evolutionarily speaking the two brain
hemispheres are separate and when you
say doesn't get involved what's the
advantage of that that detachment from
the involvement well it's it rimoni
cahal you who you know is a great
history ologist yeah and one of his
findings was in primates are more
inhibitory in neurons than in any other
animals and there are more in humans and
than in any other primate and there are
many and that's proposed speaking
proportionally proportionately and there
are more kinds as well so we think that
about 25% of the entire
cortex is is inhibitory right so it's a
very strong effect and the corpus
callosum seems to be very largely in the
end inhibiting function in the other
hemisphere and that is I think because
over time the two hemispheres have had
to specialize there are reasons why
actually it can't be I'm not going to go
into now but I was talking about just a
few days ago that the evolutionary
psychiatry meeting but there are reasons
why the corpus callosum has had to
become more selective and to inhibit
quite a lot of what's going on in the
other hemisphere because it enables the
two to do distinct things mhm and of
course they have to work together but
usually good teamwork doesn't mean
everyone trying to do the same role
right so differentiation is very
important for two elements to work
together and inhibition is one way of
doing that so effectively the two takes
on the world if you like that the
hemispheres have are not easily
compatible right and we're not aware of
that because at a level below
consciousness there's a meta control
center that is bringing them together so
in ordinary experience we don't feel
we're in two different worlds but
effectively we are and they have
different qualities and different goals
different values different different
takes on what is important in the in the
world and what meeting or whatever so
let me let me ask you about I've got
I've developed a conceptual scheme for
for thinking about the relationship
between the two hemispheres and I'm kind
of I've been curious about what you
think about it and how it might map on
to or not your your ideas so I've been
really interested in the orienting
reflex and discovered by so club I think
back in about 1962 right he was a
student of Laureus and the orienting
reflex is manifested when something at
least in their terminology something
unpredictable happened i've thought much
more recently than it's actually when
something undesired happened happens and
the laboratory constraints obscured that
and that turned out to actually be
important but good um so and i kind of
put together the ideas
the orang ting reflex with some of the
things I learned from Jung Jung's
observations on the function of art and
dreams so imagine that you have a
conceptual scheme laid out right we
could say that it's it's it's
linguistically media its enforced on the
world and then there are exceptions to
that to that conceptual scheme those are
anomalies that are unexpected and the
orienting reflex Orient's you towards
those yes and so those are things that
aren't fading property in your
conceptual scheme that you have to
figure out you know the first thing you
do is react defensively essentially
because it might be dangerous yeah and
then your exploratory systems are
activated yes so and the exploratory
systems first of all our enhanced
attention from an attentional
perspective but then and this is where
the art issue sort of creeps into it
it's the idea would be something like
the right hemisphere generates an
imaginative landscape of possibility
that could map that anomaly so you can
kind of experience that it's at night
you know like say you're sitting alone
at night it's 2:00 or 3:00 in the
morning you're kind of tired maybe
you're in an unfamiliar place and
there's a noise that happens that
shouldn't happen in another room yep you
can play with that so for example if you
open the door slightly and put your hand
in to turn on the light and you watch
what happens your mind will fill with
imaginative representations of what
might be a route is right so it's like
the the the landscape of anomaly will be
populated with something like
imaginative demons yes and that's a
first pass approximation and it seems to
me that that's a right hemispheric
function and then that as you explore
further that imaginative domain which
which circumscribes what might be is
restrained and constrained and
constrained and constrained until you
get what it actually is and that's
specialized and realized it's something
like that yeah does that seem like a
reasonable what do you think about that
I love that host of reasons one is you
mentioned defense and one of the ideas
behind my hypothesis is the right
hemisphere is on the lookout for
predators right whereas the left
hemisphere is looking for prey and this
has been confirmed in many species of
things I'd never heard
second part amphibians and mammals yes
[Music]
so and you're in left hemispheric mode
you're more in predator Morgan Williams
well I mean of course we are not lizards
or toads or marmoset or whatever but in
animals generally speaking yeah this is
the case getting in grasping and after
all our left hemisphere is the one that
controls the grasping head is left
hemisphere and exploring which you
mentioned yeah is more right hemisphere
and when the when a frontal function is
deficient people often go into warm
somatic mode of the hand of that side
and the left hand it's usually
exploratory motions meaningless ones but
trying to explore the environment and
with the right hand its grasping
pointlessly at things so they as where
they're automatic thing is with the with
the left hand the right hemisphere to
explore with the right hand the left
hemisphere to grasp so when you said
exploratory and you said defense and you
said also opening up to possibilities
these are all aspects or the way the
right hemisphere I often say the right
hemisphere opens up to possibilities
right whereas the left hemisphere wants
to close down to a certainty right and
you need chaos an order and and you know
I loved in your talk you talked about a
chaos and order but if I may say so you
seemed and maybe you'd like to gloss
that a little you seem to suggest that
it would be good we can't get rid of
chaos but you've seemed to imply that
would be better if we could whereas my
view is that chaos and order are
necessary to one another and there is a
proper sort of harmony balance okay I
think that's that's as deep a question
as you could possibly ask I would say
because I'm saying some of them I would
say there's a central theological issue
there and yes you there's the you know
in Genesis the proper environment of
humanity is construed as a garden yes
and so I see that as the optimal balance
of chaos and order nice nature is
flourish isn't it prolific and is
chaotic
yeah then if you add harmony to that you
garden yes where you live in the garden
you're supposed to tend the garden okay
so now the garden is created it's a
walled space yes even as a walled space
yeah Ferriday side so it's a walled
garden that's it now the thing is as
soon as you make a wall you try to keep
what's outside out but you can't because
the boundaries between things are
permeable so if you're going to have
reality and you're gonna have a bounded
space you're gonna have a snake in the
garden yes
now then the question is what the hell
should you do about that make the
walls so high that no snake can possibly
get in or should or should you allow for
the possibility of snakes but make
yourself strong enough so that you can
contend with them and I think there's
there's an answer there that goes deep
to the question of even maybe why the
theological question of why God allowed
evil to exist in the world I agree with
you it's like well do you make people
safe or strong and strong is better and
safe might not be commensurate with
being like it might not be possible to
exist and to be safe well our existence
is predicated on the fact that we dies
well what's never safe well it's
certainly bounded yeah this inevitably
wrapped up with you sort of finitude
yeah there's this there's a lovely
lovely Jewish idea and ancient ideas one
of the most profound ideas I've ever
come across and so it's a kind of a Zen
koan and here it is is that so it's a
question about the classic attributes of
God omniscient omnipresent and
omnipotent hmm what is it being with
those three attributes Locke mm-hmm what
kind of question is that
the answer is limitation yeah and the
second answer is that's the
justification for being is that the
unlimited lacks the limited exactly and
so because a limited is us for anything
to come into existence there needs to be
an element of resistance and so things
are never predicated on one pole of what
is always a dipole right
everything is has that type oh yes it is
and it's imaged in the yin-yang idea but
it seems to me very important because in
our culture we often seem to suppose
that certain things are just good and
other things are just bad and it'd be
good if we could get rid of the bad ones
but actually by pursuing
certain good things that are good within
measure too far they become bad not so
cool right but now let's go back to your
a normally thing because Ramachandran
calls the right hemisphere the unnormal
yes yes and so I think that that's a
very important point because there are
two ways you can react to an anomaly
one is to and both have to be explored
one is to try and prove that it's not
really an anomaly and therefore you can
carry on with things as normal
yes and the other is hopeful that's that
you hope that that's it that's the
that's the typical left hemisphere
approach doesn't want anything to have
to shift yeah and quite reasonably you
don't want to be chaotically shifting if
you're onto a good thing too stressful
exactly it takes too much work it and
you might actually be mistaken in a way
it's perfectly correct to be wary but
it's not correct to be so wary that you
blot out anomalies and there's a lot of
evidence as I'm sure you know that the
left hemisphere simply blocks out
everything that doesn't fit with its
take it doesn't see it acting at all
right so it's there's a hugely important
element in the right hemisphere going
hang on but there may be another way of
thinking that will accommodate this
better and actually good science needs
yes to be skeptical about anomalies
otherwise the be chaos it also needs to
be able to shift when an anomaly is
rightly large enough right right or
there is quite a lot of them and they
don't really fit very well into this
exactly yes yes so there's there's
another observation that Jung made which
I loved I love this observation he was
trying to account for radical
personality transformation right and so
his idea was this and I think it's it's
it's commensurate with the ideas of
inhibition between the two hemispheres
so let's imagine the left is habitually
inhibiting the function of the right to
keep fear under control it does that all
sorts of ways but so imagine that the
right is reacting to anomalies and it's
aggregating them okay the left can't
deal with them so the right is
aggregating anomalies and maybe that's
starting to manifest itself and
nightmarish dreams for examples like
that these normally sir piling up it's
indication that you're on shifting sand
well so then imagine that the right
hemisphere aggregates anomalies and then
it starts to detect patterns in the
anomalies and so now it starts to
generate
what you might consider a counter
hypothesis and the left psychosis if
that counter hypothesis gets to the
point where the total sum in some sense
of the anomalies plus the already mapped
territory can be mapped by that new
pattern then at some point it will shift
yes and the person will kick into a new
yes now it's like a piagetian stage
transition except more dramatic it is
and what a fusion stage transition is
also like and subsumes those is regalian
Alf fable the idea that a thing is
opposed by something else
but when it when there is a synthesis
it's not that one of them is annihilated
right there both transformed and taken
up into the new hole which embraces what
before looks like look like an
opposition okay so here's a question for
you you know when I read Thomas Kuhn I
was reading to a PSA at the same time
and I knew that PSA was aware of codes
work by the way and the problem I had
with cone and the interpretation
interpreters of Kuhn is they don't seem
to get something who interpret Kuhn has
a moral relativist in some sense yeah
you don't seem to get the idea of
increased generalizability of a plan so
let's say I have a theory and a bunch of
anomalies accrue and I have to wipe out
the theory and so then I wipe out the
theory and I incorporate the anomalies
and now I have another theories yeah
it's a descent into chaos that's my
estimation okay old story so the anomaly
yeah disruption is the mythical descent
into chaos yes and then you reconfigure
the theory with the chaos and you come
up with a better theory yes okay the
reservoir is it better and the answer is
what accounts for everything that the
previous theory accounted for plus the
anomaly exactly so there's progress
always yes exactly
but Kuhn is often read as stating that
there is no progress that you know
there's incommensurate paradigms and you
had a just shift between them but yeah
there isn't there is a cumulative
knowledge in some sense well I think one
thing that when we probably would both
agree about is that we don't buy as a
story that you know because nothing can
be demonstrated definitively utterly to
be the
there is no truth I mean I think we both
believe that there are truths things
that are truer than other things and
indeed if the actor well we couldn't
even talk correctly if we did exam and
even to say that there are no truths is
itself a truth statement which is it's
truer than the statement there are
truths so everybody automatically has
choose whether they know it or not yes
because while you and you said why I
don't think it's not only that you can't
talk you can't even see no because you
don't know how to point you wouldn't
know how to discriminate what's coming
into your brain so it's inevitable and I
think we would agree about that but I
think that may be a slight point of
difference between us in that I'm very
willing to embrace the idea of
uncertainty and Isis I may be wrong
perhaps you could expand on that but
sometimes you come across as as a man
who has certainties this well it's a
peculiar kind of certainty I'm certain
that standing on the border between
order and chaos is a good idea that's a
weird exactly because that you need to
be in this sort of slightly unstable
position yes you have to you have to be
what would you say encountering as much
uncertainty as you can voluntarily
tolerate yes I think that's equivalent
to vygotsky's zone of proximal
development I'm sorry so when we talked
a little bit earlier about the idea of
an instinct for meaning yeah so I think
what meaning is it's it's it's the
elaborated form of the orienting reflex
but what meaning does its function its
biological function which I think is
more real in some sense than any other
biological function is to tell you when
you're in the place where you've
balanced the stability let's say of your
left hemisphere systems with the
exploratory capacity of your right so
that not only are you master of your
domain but you're expanding that domain
simultaneous it and when you I think
that when you're there yeah it's a it's
a it's a kind of a metaphysical place in
some sense that you're imbued with a
sense of meaning and purpose and that's
an indication that you actually
optimized your neurological function yes
and the perhaps we could gloss the idea
of purpose because I think there's
a difference between people get very
confused I think about the idea of
purpose particularly whether there's a
problem that suggesting there is a
purpose and I believe there is a purpose
or there are purposes to the cosmos not
just to my and suggest that somehow it's
all been predetermined by God but this
is to misunderstand the nature of time
that there are time static slices and
God as there and he's sorted it all out
and the whole thing's just unfolding as
birdsong says like a ladies fan being
unfurl is extremely boring and and and
and an entirely static and non creative
universe but actually something is at
stake things are unfolding they have
overall a direction but actually exactly
what that direction is isn't know what
it looks like and it's a fool who says
anything positive about the nature of
God but but I'm not convinced that God
is omniscient and omnipotent either I
think God is in the process of is
becoming God is not only just becoming
but is becoming epidemic yeah so being
and becoming more becoming I think
becoming is the important thing why do
you think that I mean it's also a
strange segue I mean I'm not criticizing
but I'm curious what what drove you to
that conclusion an awful lot of thing is
really and I think that everything is is
a process in fact I'm writing a book
called there are no things oh there are
processes yes and there are patterns
patterns yes well I think music is so
powerful music is one of the most
mysterious and wonderful things in the
universe and I don't think it's at all
foolish of people to have thought that
the you know planetary motions were kind
of music I think it is a very important
insight now the music you know I've
thought and I've said this in public
lectures that music is the most
representative of the Arts it is the
world's music describes how those
patterns should be arranged you're using
representative in a very different way
no
depends on what you mean by represent so
it's representing the ultimate reality
of the cosmos what I would like to say
that presentative inner that it's not
representing anything it is actually
when we're in the presence of music
something is coming into being which is
which is at the core of the whole cosmic
process and I think that's what love
music they do and I mean I'm hardly any
originality in the idea cause lots of
physicists say this they're the sort of
the movements of atoms and the movements
of planets and so forth are more like a
dance or more like music than they are
like things bumping into it right and so
a lot of things there's patterns that
people have made into tools I agree with
you and tools of what the left
hemisphere is always looking for it's
always like insanity didn't pass right
it rare phase processes that if you it's
all a matter of time every single thing
including the mountain behind my house
if you were able to which is billions of
years old if you were able to take and
as it were a series of like a time-lapse
camera you'd see the thing morphing and
changing and flowing everything flows as
Heraclitus once said everything flows
it's just a question of over the time
period that you consider it temple it's
a question of the tenure and so taking
time out of things and considering them
in the abstract deracinated from context
particularly from the flow and from the
context of time changes them into
something else and I think that what in
brief what Plato has done and what a lot
of the history of more recent
Christianity has done is to thing if I
God and heaven perfect states that are
unaltered and so on and I think that it
is an ever evermore wonderfully self
self exploring self actualizing process
that requires a degree of opposition you
know as a stream in order to have the
movement and the and the ideas and
patterns in it that when I experienced
it's hard to describe these experience
but when I've contemplated death deeply
it has struck me as a as a fundamental
repair mechanism like it's part of the
mechanism by which new things that are
better are brought in to be absolute and
I mean you see that in your own being
yes of course without death you couldn't
live yes because you're dying the things
about you that aren't right even though
the physiological level are dying all
the time they are unfortunately you also
completely die which is unfortunate side
but more more cosmically speaking it
does seem to me that death is the is its
I don't know man it's I've had
intuitions or intimations the death is
the friend of being and that's like it's
hard to get my head around that I
completely agree with you and indeed
that's been said by many many many ways
of people than myself I think that's
right that death is predicated on life
but also is it it shouldn't be seen as a
sort of something that's negative it's
it's a necessary stage in the process of
being becoming what it is and since
everything is ramified since nothing is
just isolated you and i may look as
though feel as though but as you often
eloquently say we all have in time we
come from a place but also as a culture
we have history we can't detach
ourselves from it we're expressions of
it but we're also inevitably dependent
as all organisms are on the environment
where I end and where the great
environment begins is a I didn't like
the word environment it's not a nature
it's just something that's always been
born whereas environments there's
something around me from which I'm
separate but but anyway all of that is
close to yes yes so I would see us as
like an eddy in a stream or like a wave
in the sea that is never set for
Schrodinger life is really I
mean the comings together of physics
with with this with the process
philosophy is a very strong when does
that book come out when I finished
writing oh yeah and I I'm very worried
that it's getting bigger and is you know
all the time I'm writing it I'm seeing
more and more of
things that I am really must get to know
more about and it's an ever receding
well it's a danger of a book that I know
that aims at something fundamental
because I never run you never hit the
proper boundaries that's it I need that
wool mhm yes yeah well I also had
experiences I would say that when I was
trying to understand their imaginative
experiences when I was trying to
understand let's say the necessity of
evil hmm no because that's also a
fundamental theological conundrum and
yeah a metaphysical conundrum you know
why is it that being is constituted such
that evil is allowed to exist and it's
even chromosomes what critique of of
Alyosha's christianity essentially what
kind of God would allow for this sort of
thing that's the ancient question yeah
it's an ancient question and I mean part
of what I thought but I mean I thought
about the adversarial I went to that
which is that you need a challenge
because you don't you're not forced to
bring forth what you could bring forth
without a challenge and the greater the
thing that you're supposed to bring
forth the greater the challenge has to
be yeah I need an adversary something
like that but then I also thought that
um it would it's possible that that that
being being requires limitation you
might say optimal being requires free
choice I know I'm going through a lot of
things quickly free choice requires the
real distinction between good and evil
is that you don't have choice well so
maybe it's possible to set up a world
where evil is a possibility but where it
isn't something that has to be manifest
you know where it's an option open to
you and a real option and it has to be
and the challenge that was presented to
you but it's something that you can not
you can not move towards if you soul if
you so desire and that seems to me to be
something like the ethical ethical
requirement that that's the fundamental
ethical requirement to avoid evil I'm
sure doesn't mean it shouldn't exist
that's not the same issue there it isn't
it isn't and I wonder what could recast
it as the need for other nurse and God
needs something other and that other if
it's not going to be just part of God
has got to be free otherwise there will
be no creation I mean the the nature
that there is some
other than than God it may in the end
come from and come back to right that
God well with that divine essence all
that whatever but there's a wonderful
thing I can't figure out either like in
the Christian idea there's the end of
time where the the evil is separated
from God from yeah and I think about
that as a metaphysical well you might
think if it's a form of like imagines
it's a form of perfection a form of
striving for perfection you fragment
yourself yes you challenge yourself yeah
throw what's not worthy into the fire
elastic something like that and so what
it what you end up with retained is much
better than what you started with
through the trials something like that
well that sounds a bit like the
dialectical process that we were talking
it right and you have alluded to a
couple of very good Jewish myths and
there's one in the lurin Kabbalah about
the creation which I don't if you know
it but it's it's absolutely riveting to
me and the idea is that the primary
being aims off the ground of all being
and needs something other to come into
being the creation and that creation
what does that aims off do was his first
act is it to stretch out a hand and make
something not a big the first act is to
withdraw to create a place in which
there can be something other than paint
off and so the first stage is called sim
summon is sounds- as so many creative
things do with draw and then in that
space there are vessels and a spark
comes out of aims off and falls into the
vessels and they all shatter and that's
called sefirot okay yes you right yes
and then there is the third stage repair
in which what has just been fragmented
is restored into something greater and
so this process carries on and it's in
my terms very like what happens
with the hemispheres the right
hemisphere is the one that is first
accepting it is sort of actively
receptive if you can put it that way to
whatever is new you were talking about
Hammond gobo cancer and and then
whatever that is is then sort of
processed by the left hemisphere at the
next stage in two categories so it's bit
of that yeah try to understand it but of
course whatever it is is much bigger
than any of the categories so they all
break down and it gets restored in the
right hemisphere into a new hole that
the tikkun the repair mm-hmm right tik
kuf tik right right right right
and I think that the the kind of easy
way of thinking about it is learning a
piece of music you'll first of all
attracted to it as a whole you then
realize that you need to practice that
piece of bar 28 and you realize that you
know it 64 there's a return to the
dominant or something and then actually
when you go on stage you've got to just
forget all about that but it's not that
that work was lost it's just that it's
no longer present right right